Morou a minha paixinha aqui, né?
É.
Olha, tudo bem.
Tu vai se morrer ou não?
Vou.
É.
Cadê o...
Que?
Cabo.
Estargado que está errada.
Perdoa.
É.
Sessento watts.
Quando tem mais, é...
O que é essa?
Salve-noite?
Salve-noite.
Dá pra ir para 100.
Oi.
Onde está?
Sim.
Então, vamos lá, vamos lá, vamos lá.
O que é isso?
É como é durado, tá?
Tá sempre durado, tá?
Fazendo.
E vai para a casa de um dado ali.
Feito a água, foi?
Feito a água.
Ainda não.
Fiquei ensinando o que era um limite.
Ela chega na prisão, tá?
Mas ele vai ficar na revisão, tá ligado?
Pra tirar, tá falando.
Pra tirar as fotos que tinha que falar no jeito.
Enfim.
Fazendo, então hoje,
Mas aí foi ele no meio da rua.
É só assim.
Aquela bunda de água.
Foi de alma, gente.
Fui esquecendo, né?
Fui esquecendo agora.
Fui esquecendo de ligar, né?
Sim, é...
Ah, deve ter uma marchada.
Segundo isso.
É só uma marchada.
Você não acha que tem para botar...
E aí, você tá bem?
Tá triste
Vamos lá, não?
Vamos lá.